I just whatever I know that I will be
embossed in accent huh
don't worry buddy no Phoenix I'll be
there December 21st that is a Saturday
at the celebrity theater performing I
can't wait
get your ticket to tea fake Katie fat
came out not calm then I got Boston the
Wilbur New Year's Eve at Wow I got two
shows I'm excited so no it's just one
show probably who knows either way maybe
it will be two shows then let's see
Wilbur
get your tickets for New Year's Eve
can't wait to get there and the last
January 9th they any one of the faves
I mean Salt Lake City this week Thursday
Friday Saturday Utah come get you some
white white white people Utah Salt Lake
City Utah why these guys Pasadena next
Wednesday one show only one night only
right before Thanksgiving the night
before Bryan Callen and myself and other
funny people I South Pasadena next
Wednesday
that's for 27th December Kansas City
December 6 through the 7th and then
Atlantic City Borgata New Jersey
December 14th La Jolla Comedy Store
December 19th 21st and a bunch of other
dates on there get him now tik calm ok
boomers I like that hair long dude are
we recording I mean you look Italian as
health what the people are saying do me
a favor gorgeous I look like just awful
my name is my name is Fabrice your
vision of a time just do can you good
acts on Saturday my name is ELISA me my
name is fr b2
I like the way the dick tail no don't
say that
no where's the dick take my name my name
is fr bleach oh it's my wife
say my name is Fabrizio I'm a Fabrizio
my name my name is fab bridges for peace
that's not right oh right
yeah yeah I was identical yeah now look
at me and say you're too beautiful for
me I'd die for you I'd die for you
yeah you could be a [ __ ] Italian
actor just soap opera guy dude
aye aye you are you are too beautiful
for me I die for you I die for you I
[ __ ] your mouth no no they don't say
that no no or no no no no we're not
doing a time we're doing I dumped now
we're doing [ __ ] we're doing oh god
dude I'm trying to around mozzarella
mozzarella that's mozzarella yeah I you
know you're a bumpy on your lip what you
look dumpy on your lip a bumpy you know
baby no I don't you're like a thing were
you eating past or that a bump on my you
mean our herpes sore neither be you do
you have a sword oh I know what that is
I was doing pull-ups at you know I
trained it Higa Machado's oh that's
right eight one two city blocks eight
one two six Wilshire Boulevard Beverly
Hills if you ever need me that's why I
train now listen to through you find
talent that's where you find me I was
doing I was doing take that Greco take
downs I'm so ready I can't give me a
little more time sure you might owe me
one
don't be the take back for all the time
don't be disrespectful because when I
when I represent my sensei Egon Machado
yep Alan if you want to make love you
could judge it you come on down bro but
do me a favor you come down to eight one
two six Wilshire Boulevard okay you come
correct right I'm coming correct I
respect the hell out of him
yeah come correct and finish in front of
them I need a little more time I'm gonna
pin you down not all your pants out for
any instructor know what yeah I need
more time piss on you no I don't want to
get [ __ ] drunk I'm gonna piss on your
friend you cuz oh no dude
because what are you gonna do oh how
what do you do knee on belly
no it's gonna pin you down by your neck
I'll do it don't [ __ ] the Ritz so it's
not popular Society got the rape choke
but you don't hold me like an by 1
degree Silva just like this your neck
your stupid little chicken egg no I
don't have a chicken I get out this big
every hack in this golden shower time
huh no I'm gonna see what your
instructor series getting you free
lessons after that
no more no peeing on the mat sir no piss
on the mill piss pissing on the mat yeah
were you in town this weekend it's gonna
take me a little time taking about ten
years and now I was I had town this
weekend I was in town this weekend went
to the Rams game yesterday who did you
go with I went with mr. Will Sasso we
had a black you were missed the the LA
Coliseum that can't wait for the
Inglewood because it's too old school
and the sound system is the worst the
worst you can't hear it it's
embarrassing it's embarrassing
embarrassing Rams one and there were
more Bears fans I swear to God
bears travel well bewbs beers to Cubs
the Bears are they were going so [ __ ]
crazy for I mean devoted I was rooting
for the Bears because I was in a bear
section oh wow and that's when you know
that we got some we got some fighter in
the kid fans out there oh they saw you
when you when you walk around stadium I
was kind of amazed I was like yeah don't
say you're welcome don't do that OU's do
jump you weren't yelling out for school
nothing worth no weird we didn't hear
school
oh that's trains in here the Goldbergs
do well I just made a joke about that
nobody was going call boat they were
going fighter and again you know
podcasting TMP 10-minute podcast because
me and SATs were walking around it was
so great the most but it was so [ __ ]
great no game I love doing that it is
fun yeah I had I got hooked up by Joey
over at scopa you know the guy who you
may not know him but he enjoys my Joey
runs scope and he gave me tickets and he
couldn't go and he just invited will
yeah and he came to me and I had on
field passes which we can get there in
time cuz getting there that traffic and
find the [ __ ] you with the party
hey downer he'd be in the house let it
go to gate like functions like you know
me and and I know you dude I lose energy
I can't if you won't you want me to sit
in traffic how long and then find
parking the other thing lines to get
into the LA Coliseum just to get in
you're waiting in a giant did I tell you
what I want a pumpkin patch with my girl
my family the line long I finally the
place I go do do my girl goes please
just be quiet just I'm freaked out like
yeah I've been working all day I don't
want to sit in line found one place I go
do do what's gonna take get in there
I'll give you a hundred all you guys
while I went that's why 700
that man there yes doesn't work like
that buddy he said that hey you [ __ ] I
give you a hundred bucks down for the
punk I respect it well I iced it when
there was a line my father there was
literally a line at LaGuardia or it was
at JFK we were me and 11 family members
11 now the poems we're going to
Dominican Republic and it was it was
Christmas time so the line was and my
dad who is a rule follower from
Wisconsin and a good man is standing all
the way in the back of the line and I go
I if I do this I'm gonna die dies I
don't I don't recommend this this is
[ __ ] this is shitty of me but I'm from
New York man identify more with you
Sicilian side so I go look my father I
go you how much cash you have him he
goes what I go how much cash he always
has cash he goes well I don't know and I
go give me a hundred bucks he goes what
are you gonna do I go I'm gonna get a
saddle yellow and he goes no no I go
give me $100 right now I walk to the guy
go hey bro can I ask you a quick
question
I am honored dollars now can I get my 11
family members like ahead of this line
agreed he goes come with me that was it
- come with me they were like I just am
[ __ ] yeah everybody don't gots do me you
gots to well it's like Disney and the
lines are so long I looked at I'm like
how much how much the VIP stuff and you
go through I'm like oh yeah yeah that's
where my that's where money if you have
crazy money which I don't have but if
you have crazy money like a friend of
mine who was they screwed up something
and he was in this insane line and
they're gonna wait and it was gonna be a
day before they got flying yeah my
friend goes I'm gonna get a private jet
that's what that's real money
I'm gonna get her but that's $54,000 hey
worth it how about so it's well Dyke
mange suffers from anger issues he's way
better now he's a kid is that's gonna
therapy really all awful but we are in
line in in Texas at a barbecue place and
the we've kind of a long line we're
waiting there I can see Jake you know
Jays get a little sweaty he's like this
thing seemed getting like irritable but
I it was a long line as a kite we don't
know anyone in less waiting line away
and I see Jay just kind of like the like
and then we find you to the front and
he's like god I'm so excited that's like
me too
we get there and the people in front was
going um now the brisket how was dude
they're there for 15 minutes oh my god
15 minutes and we've been waitin life
for 50 minutes they're 15 going through
all the everything and you can tell the
even the guy working there's like yeah
so you I gotta get I gotta hurry you
three all right hold on now if we get
this and it's the only time it flares up
god he's in line that's how rude oh you
dummy
Oh move it on you I even wear like this
I meant whatever if you will take I'll
pay for theirs just let let us go
forward I'll pay for whatever the [ __ ]
they're getting just let us know we're
on a time crunch I'm like please just
let us go and you're hungry
I saw Ju in the meat sweats and they've
got their own sweats
yeah and he's all white so that his next
I can all read yeah yeah he's like come
back out split oh yeah and he's every
bit of 235 240 now wasn't that that is
that the other one the pecan Lodge
that's why now that's why you're AB
you're a bar Baku freak huh love
barbecue III never I never take
advantage what's with the lemon there is
four lemon dude
you talk about the goddamn pickles you
[ __ ] that Oh pickles because and that's
just mean pickles so looks well [ __ ]
the LeSean large trough that's how we I
was able to skip some of the line
you pay yell buy six pounds or more okay
you can skip the line you can't pecan
Lodge very like top rated Zagat rated
that's Houston's that's Dallas that's in
Dallas now here's the problem though so
you got to get over six pounds we see
that Triceratops rib on the right there
I need to about three and a half your
pants Wow and I'll you I go guys get
more pork ribs and like brisket I want
that giant [ __ ] yeah whatever he
wrecks River where the [ __ ] it was
yeah they're like no Serrano rib right
oh they want to take it they got a
restoration that's a black Buffalo rib
yeah man's delicious though yeah
delicious Wow yeah hey what's that
what's that in that cup there
tater salad - that's macaroni jalapeno
macaroni
oh so that's that's mac
and cheese I don't [ __ ] with that but
dear can my brother do that looks like
cold macaroni oh it's hot very salad
it's hot that's macaroni and cheese no
cheese yeah well you're you you're your
blood after that is soup right I was
telling those guys that come I'm letting
barbecue before show anymore it's so
heavy oh yeah it's your body that's try
adjusting that [ __ ] oh dude and
everyone's all tired and then you're not
museum like let's go man and then you're
doing that with whiskey while you have
you on the whiskey you are weird and
tell you I'm gonna die but in Texas I
thought for me get drunk yeah you did I
mean yeah like I'll drink a double on
the rock before I go on stage yeah hope
for you a little buzz on sure in Texas
nothing
definitely [ __ ] up Denver you do one
those all because the altitude yeah but
in doubt your your big kid your big boy
so you need some yeah I don't know dude
I need you need more whiskey than normal
yeah they say that one drink for a man
is two for a woman because they don't
have the enzymes or something to break
it down right size too though right size
and also something to do with their
chemistry yeah dude how about new baby
comes next week oh my god boss can I say
his name yeah go ahead Boston Boston Jay
Boston Jay I'm shocked rage a shot
that's a great Boston Jay stomaching
dude I know
can't wait two boys two Rascals girls
our girls are much more complicated than
boys girls are yes yeah hello everybody
I said girls are more trouble because
girls they're just they have their deal
it's scary for girls girls oh oh in
middle school - they deal with a lot of
stuff it's it's no joke you do you watch
euphoria you don't have a girl I'm like
everyone's [ __ ] like this you guys
back in high school
um I say what's the Institute and my son
hood you try and do some alpha stuff
with me like yesterday I had to take one
of my cars out and I got him a new
little I'll post it he got a new little
car they can drive a 918 spyder it's red
and so I moved my car I'll get him used
to expensive cars he loves cars he
asking me fantastic super healthy but I
pull my car out and then I had to move
one and bring another car and he parked
his little car there here's my spot now
papa Wow yeah
like well it's not dude you enough
throws the biggest fit he didn't I park
my car there you blast the mic oh wait
so he's your three dudes parking his
tiny car Alfa move and I'm like oh no
little dude this ain't happenin do you
know and then he went come inside so I
grabbed his car moved it pulled on it
well Papa's car's gonna be in the garage
you can be next to me Mama's here
Papa's here you're gonna be here
wouldn't come inside through the biggest
fit now I want to be there I'm like are
you at your god damn are you crazy here
how crazy is now now is this the new car
yes you're driving the new one did you
bring it here is there the one with the
fin huh and there's a difference twixt
that one and the old Porsche you had
that looked like dude that was purple
night and day difference scariest car
I've ever drove these scares got like
what do you mean scariest just do a lot
of fast cars man yeah you and Rogen text
me because I you know me and Ronan big
car guys I take to him I go look what
just I went the Widowmaker just landed
that's what they call it the Widowmaker
it's so dangerous there the will we
don't make her just landed and he was
like beasts be safe in that like Roget
be safe in that thing yeah it was no
joke it's cuz he's got that ludicrous
package and that Tesla that he says it's
for gays I'm talking now let's hold on
now first of all oh my car on the track
your car even 60 shitty Ludacris yeah no
no look it up true look it up that's not
true that's not wake it up best fact
thing ever for a car that's what best
track done on the new ting Berg or
whatever the [ __ ] Jimmy that's trying to
track time ever what a listening is a is
a real race car like legit race good
hold up take it easy to tune your class
today come on bro RS yeah man and then
you want speedy Y chic package but
whatever we'll leave that out 690
horsepower well that's been freely at
700 and I really given it away they are
they
no but what are you trying to look for
it's I'm not sure what do you want we're
looking for do you want speeds use at
track times whatever you want it's fast
track time the new ting burger the [ __ ]
it is there it is new burger green
Nurburgring GTRs world record which is
basically that's like that's like a
pissing contest for any cars so fights
that think oh excuse me I could take on
the 405 for it and now now Porsche want
you go faster night because it's
government building a cop one hundred
and eleven I imported two got blood on
the car yeah because they did it to get
up to 225
watch your wheels are fall off so they
don't want you doing that your wheels
that come off yeah so it's 225 so you
can go to 211 Lamborghini set a new
record and then the gt3 gt2 RS [ __ ] on
it so now now what is the what is zero
to 60 in that bad boy don't even know
dude you're driving that car and and
does it feel like hey what is it like
it's scary I thought I've had all of its
loud right crazy loud
damn right it's loud 2.0 season 2 6 oh
my lord
so there's not there's no but there is
lag a little bit there's a little lag
because there's no lag in that Aaron bro
there's no not better the Tesla what's
Tesla what's that
computer game do what's the iPad do it
would you want model is it yes the 3/100
D or something I don't know the Tesla
Model maybe well know is that but that's
is that the oh yeah that's it all right
2.5 sorry bro sorry about that
yeah right you know why cuz there's zero
lag time are you ok I'll scroll down you
alright
zero 69 bro sorry about that goes 0-60
at 1.9 oh sorry
oh the new one oh yeah I'm sorry oh
that's that you wrote sterling I can't
compete and some video game though you
know I'm talking I'm talking gasp
but you see this 2019 we running on
dynasty Oh baby
hmm you're gonna come over I'm not
because you know who's in electric cars
as well who does it better
Porsche Porsche I it's hard to get one
of those new ones it is but I guess they
they they fooled everybody into what it
looks like because they've seen him oh
who told you that I don't know who's the
elf
we can't really show these videos so I'm
just trying to sound off but let's see
yeah just on take off for sure right
because there's no is that the gt2 drag
right Wow
yeah but yawns try a few now maybe
straight but you on the track the Newton
burger
it's whatever they're in Germany my car
your video game now don't do that don't
go listen because let me tell you why
also only one car those is worth real
money mister it's not about that you
know know you like it for a lot of
reasons a million reasons you like it
for the feat of engineering that it is
oh yeah work of art you know it's a work
of art oh yeah that that Porsche but um
I don't know how you - you just forget I
don't I don't really drive in traffic so
when I you're in what we're in first
gear most of the time right no not when
I go down like to paint a can it's a
like it's a when daddy's a big shift no
but it's a pk/pd case I can do it if I
want when Daddy leaves the comedy store
and I owe you open her up oh it's go
time
don't all right well we're though what
if you get pulled over by who what cop
can sit on Laurel Canyon think about it
yeah oppas moving now the water was we
get in trouble cuz cops hide and they're
like in dodge Rams and she's what I want
I take it real proper you do
but then Laurel can't pop open so where
do you open her up her up I'm glad four
five yeah no not four or five either to
make cops they hide yeah yellow you say
I'll do the canyons dudes cops can't be
there you can't really open her up
that's the Widowmaker no now a few
famous guys have died in Porsches yeah
let's go through it
yeah Paul Walker James Dean right James
Dean Jimmy Dean Dean Paul Walker the guy
Ryan done was actually the gt2 RS was
Ryan donek jackass Bam Margera's best
friend had a lime green these are people
who died in Porsches lights Porsches but
this is just car crashes
I bet camo Porsches linked with
celebrity deaths now James Dean died on
mahalo nice first one you had a 550
spider that's on his head oh look at
that look at look at what happens to
your head James Dean yeah I mean you
have a you have a lap belt that's this
well there's kind of Ryan Dunn does the
nine six eight no the nine eleven was
Ryan's and escape in Holyoke is the
night six eight Oh
flat nose filthy if you're in going a
car you did it right Ben really what is
that car the flat nose 930 turbo filthy
Rendon really sucks for that other guy
he wanted no [ __ ] player now Paul
Walker in a career GT that's a different
animal now why what is that ah it's just
a it means crazy car crazy car no I his
cars went up for auction
he had a bunch of cool cars just famous
but I didn't want to keep those he his
daughter like giving his daughter
millions of dollars in those cars
tark eyes even knew him really well said
he was one of the greatest guys that's
what everyone says he's all walking such
a badass such a really down-to-earth
person yeah dude you know who's a badass
Tanner's percentage of food truck with
him or hey Mazz little man I'm so
jealous I I just
he's such a badass I'd love to meet that
guy he's nice don't hurry up and get out
here for Brian Kevin look at his hair
he's here Street Jesus
yeah man came up in a very cushy way
lots of money lots of the presents at
Christmas
he's an introvert man yeah introvert
just wants to be somebody kind of on his
own you know he's paid his dues the cat
he's got a big career in the world
what yeah he's got the most authentic no
wife two kids no wife okay go
I didn't know that and I told my [ __ ]
II went to Miami
best-looking women I've ever seen my
life feels oh yeah yeah how are you
seeing us oh yeah yeah all right she's
not busting any nuts no no no girls
don't like a champion like that a badass
straight-up bad a handsome guy with that
hair it was as good as it gets it hit
what he does has a plan open out the
cart a little cameo back there now makes
sense for he's in the car shop because I
see the holy man that color that rear
color we're not talking about the Prius
right there he took my pen yeah I'm yeah
I'm talking about the Miami blue yeah
what food truck did you guys you know
what for him we didn't do a food truck
he want really good sushi and we're kind
of look around for food trucks so we had
really good sushi brought in we had a
waiter oh so he didn't know so during
the middle conversation I was like dude
already next fight and then this way she
came out with this really good sushi
yeah that's very
yeah I was because you're the baddest
[ __ ] on planet I didn't do food
truck
I brought real sushi to you I wait Hanzo
or whatever [ __ ] you that and then like
this guy no tuxedo came out brother very
funny
yeah now does he um is he training right
an hour as he taken it easy
uh he's out here for stem cells oh wow
jeez yeah great to just like solid yes
also regular yeah almost a mom mostly
guys are man but he's just I mean such a
sweet person
yeah that's a kind soul has he ever so
style been there like this these these
guys man there's like they're just so
authentic and genuine you can't help but
love them then you just can't well my
feeling is that they're both they're
actually characters they're colorful
characters like you love to watch them
they know how to turn around that they
they know how to be showman but part of
the way they're showman is that they're
really authentic like they back up what
they say but but with horrace nothing's
playing and none of it's like he doesn't
want to do interviews he doesn't want to
do that stuff like when bannard nacre
them talk [ __ ] like it's for him it's
personal yes so but he's not doing
anything like that he doesn't think of
anything preconceived like honor chill
right he just he doesn't want to be in
the spotlight
yeah she wants a lot of money and the
best fight
yeah that's why once who is stopping a
to like he doesn't want these super
fights he doesn't want this you know
yeah like that that whole dancing in
that left him he would do that whether
it was at Marvel Arena in front of a
hundred thousand people or a fee was
fighting in a backyard he'd be doing
those same will he fight it 55 over
he'll go to 70 Maz Vidal floats between
but Oh fight at 70 hue 50 fights gotta
be hard for him to make 25 stuff he's
done it but he would do it before it
could be he would do it for could be who
free could be how do you saw that could
be problem it the up Jorge's in a great
position because this was our
conversation I don't know when they
release it but it was like like she's
bigger than the belt like he's a bigger
name than both the guys fighting for the
title yeah so he doesn't really care so
he wants Nick Diaz or which Nick wants
him or he wants gotta McGregor he's a I
don't care about the belt like I I'm
bigger like he's right he's bigger than
the belt with the bell icon is kind of
intriguing to me but I mean Connor at
this point but because Connors boxing is
really good his striking and I feel like
they'd they'd box it out yeah however
Jorge would also kick Connor in his legs
and his body home can kick too though
yeah not like Jorge not that not with
that like Vegas kicker with with Nate
Diaz he was just laying to those ribs
though you know that that's front kick
beside you know what I mean so and he'll
and although I don't like to do Conner
Burriss Jorge next yeah
Connor spray Connors gonna fight cowboy
in January and what he is kind of like
what Jorge want that's the plan that's
what they want and what Jorge wants is
to be on the co-main event against Nick
Diaz and I know Nick wants to fight and
they've reached out to his team so
that'd be January 18 yeah Nick TS it's a
great conversation though he was
fantastic can't help but love the guy
he's got to go correct me if I'm wrong
though Whisman is ultimately enough to
do anything that's what was our
conversation he not do anything yeah
well he would fight for the 55 title no
70 he'd go for see stay at 70 so yeah he
don't know your thighs advice could be
yeah baby see a 70 welterweight right
yeah it's interesting cuz Guzman and
Colby are third and fourth curates
Israel
Wow he's alien photo title I'm bigger
than the title which he's way more
famous than both guys he's right
yeah he's striking one problem he's such
a Knopf a bigger win he's never really
lost he's lost controversial decisions
yeah like who has he actually been
actually I've never finished never love
you see that's yeah that's like Nick
Diaz I'm in his prime Nick never was
really put down he got he got put down
by Paul Daley and then came back and
knocked Paul Daley out with the same
well they got finished by Josh Thompson
knate knate they don't know yeah but
Nick I'm told Nick
nothing it's different Nick was always
like just phenomenal that way you can
even with Nick I was about five years
yeah fought who was his last fight him
since over that was so weird what he's
doing yeah yeah it's gonna be right
though I'm intrigued by that fight
actually I bet it happens really that it
happens yeah yeah what'd you do this
weekend mmm I ended up going to the
peppermint Club I watched my friends
band play what's the peppermint Club uh
it's this like little like bar by like
West Hollywood like Beverly Center
it's your famous um I don't know I mean
I'm here to stop no you know when I was
down what the Rams game is you're
driving back that's where those those
strip clubs like deja vu and the playpen
yeah I've not been but you drive by and
you think to yourself this isn't a very
industrial kind of area that you feel
like it's kind of lawless and you know
you got in there some boom-boom room you
know what I mean like a boom-boom room
is I like it you're not I mean love that
[ __ ] I mean there's some there's some
Bop and gandhari going on I think so
that's way you'd imagine there'd be some
[ __ ] are we going on in those places cuz
you gotta trudge down to the middle of
like downtown LA but not even where the
warehouses are the outskirts
you understand big ol warehouses then
oops the playpen Dasia what have we here
whoops not a wad full of cash yeah not a
strip club guy but listen if you're
gonna go down and you don't want to be
see good place to go throw a hat on
maybe a fake beard that's too much
mask well what kind of music did your
friend play I don't know what you you
would even say honestly but it was fine
genre would you say I mean I don't know
like it's really I'm not great with
music I just kind of be up there on
stage he was even performing his friends
were performing I don't know what
exactly it is he does for the band but
he said that ends with someone else
who's playing I don't know he said that
it was his band playing and then I got
there and realized he doesn't play an
instrument and he doesn't sing so I
don't know he manages them maybe I don't
know who's needed who is this kid to you
huh my friend from USC hmm yeah not too
close but see him every now and then
chin so once to some breweries by
yourself no hold man
[Music]
I mean I mean we don't know be more
general just some brew other dudes my
friends downtown LA are your friends
they were cool people you met him yeah
he came he brought some friends from one
of them oh yeah yeah hey what if you're
going to New York on Wednesday when you
get back Sunday okay why cuz we have
that shred thyselves together the night
before Thanksgiving oh yeah ice house
27th I think yeah 27th I'll be back I'll
be back maybe I'll come back Monday
morning Podcast good is dead dove go
back devil unpack you don't actually
spent the weekend in San Diego at the
American comedy club that's right so
good hanging with him I loved up I
didn't see mister the last yeah you
gotta hang with him we'll get him out of
here again he's so much fun but New York
I'll go see my parents see at the
apartment great Jimmy Burke huh they're
your parents that's it I'm gonna stay
pry it this Soho grand or something you
know I mean do it right at a hotel to
stay the parent I'm a grown man
yeah I feel like a loser I'm a grown man
yeah I mean let me get something to get
myself a [ __ ] hotel I Love New York
man you know I'm saying [ __ ] yeah I can
turn I can't you know jump a little
money on the dude drop a little money
that's all drop it
a problem dropper daddy daddy drop it
daddy all right do some kinda vents what
actually makes a better toothbrush you
ever think about that
is it industrial strength power is it
you know I've been greedy take my
regular toothbrush I attached an old
pager to it and have it ride by break
like this well that's that's one way to
do it and I like it cuz Dennis will tell
you it's about how you use the
toothbrush okay
and that's why quip was created by
dentists and product designers to focus
on what actually matters for your oral
health yak we've got sensitive
vibrations with a built-in timer gently
brushing for the dentist recommended two
minutes with 30 second pulses ensuring
your teeth are white you want an even
clean I call it an even clean all right
we need a quick can you please says this
because his teeth are brown men are
yellow well yeah and they sent and every
three months they'll send you new clean
bristles right on schedule
it's an intuitive design III have these
for my children and they use them
because they kids never want to brush
their yeah good habits matter right look
a healthier life so help form fresh oral
health habits with your kid with quip
starts at just $25 and you get your
first refill free I get quipped calm
slash fighter that's get quip qu IP calm
slash fighter get your first refill for
e get right now get quip concise writer
dude eight weeks to eight pack abs are
you kidding me
oh no eight weeks oh it's called ionic
dude I need to get on come on you can
get those kinds of exercises you know
nutrition fitness apparel all that stuff
and I hate to I hate to bring it to
attention um you know next week's there
Black Friday and it gets black it gets
black it gets black not a deal you got
everything you got exercise equipment
you can stock your whole gym with
everything you need gym equipment the
best moments on planets go to AH Netcom
slash fighter 10% off the whole damn
sign ballistic medicine balls out sand
bad hydric or barbells man it's cool
audit Dom / fighter for 10% off the
entire dam site you're welcome
Koran events we've got some car in a van
here we go first one okay so do you guys
know who Liz oh is I don't know [ __ ]
they're so not I listen Liz out she
sings that song uh truth hurts
nananananana Minnesota Vikings you know
about fat black girl
I don't okay well she was a very popular
song here's my thing is her whole thing
is like it's okay to be fat fat school
it's just unhealthy I just promoted
unhealthiness oh really yeah like never
in fact goes like yeah you ride girl
[ __ ] the gym yeah but no yeah but have
some self discipline up so little self
oh yes okay she's thick out and I get
everyone's beautiful okay I get it
hmm yeah this is all this it's gonna
think this is all this stuff like so
when I hear um the New York Times report
on homelessness in California okay
they never [ __ ] once mention all the
mentions people lose their jobs and they
don't have us they never once mentioned
drug addiction or alcoholism they never
mentioned mental illness they they're
just lying to all of us drive around go
to go to the basically a shantytown in
Venice go take a look at who's in those
tents they're high as [ __ ] all the time
like insane kind of thing is this it's
like this is all beautiful and
everything else but what are we what are
you saying like what are we trying to
say like you're you there there there is
a factor of like it's not that healthy
it's just unhealthy but up but I'm so
like we're just self-discipline not when
was self discipline not sexy yeah I get
where it's like Oh be yourself and be
your true self I'm with that that's fine
you'll have to be a fat shame you and
there's nothing you have to be a model
at the same time too it can't just be
like yeah eat whatever you want whenever
you want and still live your truth it's
like well no there are men that find
this very attractive so there is that to
some dudes are all and then she's out
there just oh please do not send me
poems letters or pains if your side
[ __ ] is still playing dress up in your
home I'm doing great leave me alone Wow
she's at now I'm she's owning her I look
who liked it Derek poster
you did unbelievable their legacy Wow
guys like Derrick Wow
guys like Derrick likes a tubby girl
there you go you've read the cops like
you go girl that shit's hot oh that's
fire stop it stop it there's nothing
wrong don't [ __ ] you relate to this girl
no you can't
so I'm guessing stop playing come ride
my unicorn horn that's work that keeps
going down just give me five minutes and
30 seconds all right keep going
cement lover god bless can I please
borrow your self-confidence
I'm just saying live your truth girl if
that's what you like own it but let's
not pretend it's healthy let me see some
more pictures she's talented pretty fun
pretty face well it's interesting that
you're talking about that because the
reason why she's in the news is that
she's currently being sued by a post
mates worker for an incident that
happened back in September so she
blasted this screenshot from her phone
of her post mates person who was coming
to deliver food and she tweeted it out
added postmates saying that the girl who
was supposed to come deliver her food
ended up stealing it and it had like a
photo of her as well as her name Tiffany
and then like the first initial when
that happened the post mates worker said
that she came and she said that it was
at a hotel she didn't have a room number
to go to she tried calling the person
for 10 minutes and nobody picked up she
went to the front desk the front desk
said that they didn't have anyone by the
name the under was order which was a Liz
OHS stage name or her actual name so she
didn't know I liked how I was
apologizing I paused I wasn't that girl
you know why she balled up cuz she got
called out on the whole she posted girls
face yeah so my years of followers on
your post gonna get her 6-inch sub
that's not right
yeah she tweeted out something along
lines of post mates your worker stole my
food you're lucky that I don't fight
anybody at post mates this girl Tiffany
W stole my food she's lucky I don't
fight no more yeah shortly after she
took down the tweet and apologized
saying that she
he forgets that she has such a large
following and that she shouldn't have
had put that woman on blast that woman
actually ended up quitting post mates
maybe a couple days after cuz her family
and friends saw saw it and was like hey
your photo is everywhere I mean what are
the odds that you keep on working at
post mates and somebody recognizes that
it's you so she's now suing Liz o for
defamation and like that's an actual
legit Liz o didn't get a ravioli
that's only JIT lawsuit you can't do
that no you can't do that
it's actually it is dangerous too but at
least really be more responsible my use
of social media and check my petty and
my pride at the door alright yeah I'm
not mad at this room for appalling I'm
just there's room for she got mad she
was hungry grouchy and she flipped out
in the moment but be better be better
how old is he um I think mid to late 20s
old enough to know better in my opinion
nobody's stealing your goddam she's 31
nevermind 31 now Billy Eilish didn't
she's 17 yeah then you can flip out and
postmates you're 17 grow up the world is
your oyster
you're a Liz oh and you're eating all
the oysters you can't always snitch like
that dude I haven't heard from cardi B
in a while you guys are up on this Isle
of could it be yeah I think she just got
done film was the other one grief who's
the other one she had beef with Nikki
she retired she did yeah she got married
and now she isn't making music hmm well
yeah I love me some party B though what
else you got
try to B's body's reading cos ridiculous
so a woman in Argentina tried smuggling
nine pounds of weed through an airport
and she got caught this is the photo
that they put unbelievable people I
sometimes that's hilarious oh yeah she
thought she was gonna get away with it
you don't look pregnant no it looks so
outlandish and what the TSA was like
alright well yeah it's just it's clearly
she's hiding something so she didn't get
very far
hilarious i scan you two all right so
you don't need a scan you just kind of
like know go through the skin if you're
pregnant because the rate mom but
they're like is what are you doing and
then couple people wanted us to talk
about this um so I guess jay-z kind of
called out Colin Kapernick for his
workout I think you probably know more
about this than I do
so Kaepernick's went out a league for
three years right he's gone she says
he's getting ready the NFL I see both
sides the NFL was like right let's go
we're gonna give you a workout they
invite twenty teams that Atlantic
Falcons practice facilities its
orchestrated he's gonna have all these
workouts so people and teams can see him
well Cap'n Kaepernick want his team will
his people in there and the NFL which
they don't usually allow goes no hold up
you can't have all these people in here
where you have are teaming that they
come on they wanted to regulate what
cameras what media was gonna be on
Kaepernick went we want full
transparency so I'm not gonna do it here
I'm gonna do it over here now if you
just wanna play football you're probably
not gonna do that right because all 28
or 32 teams were gonna show up I think
20 teams of three do were gonna show up
give look at you give you an opportunity
but he went hold up I can't have my team
in there
[ __ ] I'm doing over here now but I
say over here I mean an hour so the NFL
teams right we're not driving an hour
eight teams did they said he did
actually look really good as an elite
throwing arm but you know you kind of
[ __ ] it on your opportunity they also
wanted to sign like this large contract
which they gave him day of he's like now
hold up I'm gonna sign all this and in
the contract from what I heard is by him
signing that it would it make him how he
can't go back and sue the NFL for
missing all that work so in the
contractors little CD so he's like am i
sign a contract be I'm not leaning limit
who comes in and out so I'm gonna do it
over here I'm with all this is that the
NFL can go okay like the NFL doesn't
need Colin Kaepernick absolutely not
they and I think one the reach so for
those of you don't know how the NFL
works every Tuesday literally every
Tuesday because team guys get hurt
they bring in guys try out for the team
I didn't know he'll bring guys in to you
know
though they can bring out throughout the
season they bring guys in huh so what's
interesting is jobs never say [ __ ]
here no never so but they could all
these teams who are interested could
have brought him in any Tuesday to work
him out right it's weird they
orchestrated this big kind of Atlantic
Falcons workout invited all the teams
people think is because jay-z has a
relationship with the NFL he forced them
to do it
so but there's I I see both sides but
jay-z's disappointed and jay-z's a
liaison for the NFL now and so on to
help out to help the relationship with
African Americans and the culture and
stuff like that he's the liaison so to
jay-z's point he's kind of like hold up
dude we finally get your workout with 20
teams and you're worried about your team
coming in and the narrative like how bad
do you want play football right when I
first also like how bad do you want
played football dude come on all 20 you
know more about this new always said
that Khan cavern AK was wasn't doing
that well anyway he was doing well but
doing well in quarterback yeah the
problem is yeah I don't know if you'd be
starting now that like the Bears could
use them the Broncos could use them
Miami there's a few teams who definitely
the Bears Carolina he could probably fit
on a team it's just what did jay-z say
and jay-z was really disappointed in him
moving the workout elsewhere and he says
that he believes that Colin Kaepernick
did it more as a PR stunt then for him
to actually get back onto that team I
think jay-z is just really upset by him
pulling all these strings trying to get
this open workout with all these teams
for Colin Kaepernick only to have him
kind of make a big deal out of the
situation and then move the work out to
somewhere else because now he feels like
it's a publicity stunt it's not
necessarily about getting him back into
footballing if it was just about
football
he was shut up and just went to that
workout and see what happens but it's
like more you know yeah I don't know
help Collins handle it to like you
already see him out there either like
moving the needle as far as equal rights
and police brutality like he's not
giving out they're giving speeches
around City City go on tour you know
going to where there's actual issues so
I don't know man I don't know I can
understand how jay-z and the another and
Scouts like to [ __ ] this guy I thought
if we show up and then you wanted an
hour this way so our distraction
it's also of the biggest yeah and you
will have I'll tell you this in America
if Colin Kaepernick is on your team
you're not gonna you're gonna piss off
of sizeable portion of your population
which is fine as you want to do that but
also at the minute he starts doing
poorly we're going to take even more in
Tebow suffers from the same curse is
when you have that when you when your
name is bigger than football when you're
a backup or whatever it is it puts so
much more pressure on the team it just
put so much more scrutiny and like
eyeballs on things why'd you why'd you
hire him if you're not doing well if you
weren't a Superbowl great you know well
where is if Collins number one goes play
football he would have done this hmm and
Steve if you have you see what Steve and
a Smith said because the other guy the
safety I forget his name
there's a safety who also too can kneel
with him put up Steve a Smith
scrutinizes Kaepernick but there's a
safety who did it oh dude but the guy
went out Steve Naismith don't [ __ ] with
Stevens dude where do you see these
tweets now he there it is he lit him up
so then so let me get this straight
worse hairline ever whatever Colin
Kaepernick has been working out all of
this time him people in this camp his
closed ones loved ones everybody talked
about he wants to play football he wants
to play football he's ready to play just
give him the chance so what does the NFL
do recognizing that teams need a shield
because they need something to hide
behind because they know that guess what
if we bring this brother in for a
workout and we don't like him or we
don't want him who knows what we're
going to get accused of we need cover so
the NFL provides that I have no doubt
jay-z's involved I have no doubt Roger
Goodell is involved I have no doubt
there's a host of people of baba faqir
all of that this man one of the chance
25 teams show up in Georgia at the
Atlanta Falcons practice facility stayed
at our facility NFL personnel equipment
everything video everything
and what does Colin Kaepernick do not
Tuesday when he found out about it now
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday three
hours before the workout because of some
issue with a liability waiver collar
Catholic wants to change the venue kylie
captain wants his own receivers Colin
Catholic once the video thinks himself
Colin Kaepernick wants the media this
collar Catholic comedian can't find him
he's got no interviews he talked to
nobody I mean you can't find him but he
wants to do in it he wants to be the
available now host except you see you
see
he don't want to play not like this
camera angle he wants to be a martyr
that's right but guess what
I love it any working this time all of
us believe that Colin Kaepernick would
have showed out and if he had showed out
I'm here to tell you who the other time
I believe he would have had a job inside
of two weeks
agreed the burial is something like but
it didn't happen cuz he did show he
wanted to show up to a high school in
Georgia now you get out of here and it's
the guy who also took in the of--they I
forget his name go back it's on social
media Oh Dominic no no not call it nope
nope nope no it's Stephen a Smith
oair Creek Steve me Smith oh there you
go Fox News the middle one dude and see
where it just drops backs on this dude
so Eric Reid is the guy who also sat out
with him and his plane then I felt
currently so Eric Reid puts at CMA Smith
tap-dancing for the NFL like I know what
that is damn straight Colin wants to
control the narrative he's supposed to
trust the organization that blackballed
him and has done absolutely nothing in
good faith born on Tuesday just not last
Tuesday at Steve Naismith right so
Steven Smith goes keeps throwing out
don't play the video here he goes dude
Malcolm X said if you're not careful
this is Eric Rita's you hating the
people who are being oppressed and
loving the people who are doing the
oppressing you embody this quote you
Malcolm Jenkins and jay-z prance around
doing the NFL's bidding to try to bury
Cohn I stand for truth and justice above
all else you're missing you are mistaken
by thinking that because you are anybody
is black that you are spared from my
criticism especially when you've been so
blatantly on the NFL side and corrupting
her own their own process to hinder
Colin's employment now look what does
green mr. Chen right Stephen a Smith the
more you talk the more ridiculous you
sound
they read actually it's worse than I
thought since you're the one tweeting to
me hours before a damn game and speaking
of the game weren't you in a
Landen attendance for Kaepernick's
workout yesterday before having to leave
early to play it for a team in a league
you're feeling so oppressed by wasn't
that you just ask and hold on i have
more the same Malcolm X who we all
Revere for life
you just bought up you just brought up
acknowledged there were slight error
there were slight errors in his thinking
you didn't bring that up you Eric Reid
went through the same process cap was
supposed to go through and you're still
on you're still playing on Sunday but
you didn't bring that up and unlike you
walking around and doing nothing but
bitching at every turn myself and many
others in the media have religiously
called out the NFL for blackballing cap
we're religiously highlight we've
religiously highlighted the unfairness
of it all and some of us have worked
behind the scenes trying to help jay-z
and others in their quest to get cap
back in the league meanwhile what does
he agree doing complaining like he wants
to be on first take failing to stop the
run on Sundays taking money and a
[ __ ] about the NFL that every talkin
[ __ ] about it the the NFL at every
turn
but asking for that check no doubt yes
I'm the one tap-dancing why because I'm
gainfully employed while trying to
remind youngsters out out there of the
pitfalls at lying wait meanwhile someone
like you continues to throw
professionalism decorum and decency into
the white into the wind sending folks
down a dead-end path all because your
boy isn't getting precisely his way when
no one gets their way so who's the
sellout guess what it's neither of us we
just have a difference of opinion I
still respect the hell out of your
immature belligerent self but I'm going
to call it like I see it
cabinet made a mistake the way he
handled all this if he really wanted a
job in the NFL period and your
contribution to all of this doesn't help
it hurts anything about you being wrong
it's about you needing to grow the hell
up your decision your life do you yeah
yeah do we all have a different opinion
eyes but yeah keep going
I've been ready for three years I've
been denied for three years we're
waiting for the Thursday owners I'm just
not buying stop erotic I'm not right
there just I see both ways but it's just
like I think he's an egomaniac and I
think he's not he's wait he's not see I
think he's I think he's way more
valuable by not playing and he knows it
and but at him keep trying to dabble in
and because then I feels like cool
here's 20 teams if you want to play
there's 20 T's Atlanta Falcons do you
think oh this is ridiculous
you're dying for a position on team your
you're a good player you're not a great
player I think if you're a GM or you're
your owner of a team you're like hold up
this guy's making it this difficult to
give him up never hire never never I
don't even know about what he stand
carry what's that about in the only nice
brutality no one wants that in the NFL
but you know I can deal with this and
they're not gonna deal with it so he
didn't get signed right I mean eight
teams showed up but I just significantly
hurt his chances
no one's wants to deal with this I'd
like to see him play and see what
happens I love see him jump in with
Chicago or you know the Broncos we need
him now here's the question will he Neal
I don't know
it's a he's just huge chat I wouldn't
sign him no I think he sounds like a
[ __ ] diva you know uh well I don't
know what he was like as a player was he
well-liked I don't know hmm I don't know
he's fallen for the for the Niners for a
while well we see Antonio Brown come
back all depends on his assault charges
yeah he's good enough where did they're
gonna put up with it
hmm you don't want best receivers
all-time yeah so that would be he's less
of a distraction than Colin he's like
some extraction column II don't want to
write a girlfriend but yeah
what else yet Jen this year over the
weekend Kanye West did the that church
thing with a huge guy from Houston Joel
Olsteen and then one quote I saw parts
of it I watched but one quote was very
interesting he says Jesus has won the
victory because now the greatest artist
that God has ever created is working for
him so he's considering himself he's
called himself the greatest artist
here's all you have for that in rap
right I mean okay but who says that I
mean but also you're not the greatest
artist not even close
that means Michelangelo I mean what are
we talking about what even artists like
I uh if he's just befriend a hip-hop
there's argument as far as like what
he's done for the culture and like the
movement so he's insanely huge could be
number one I think he's talking about
artists period which is insane it also
arts all it's all relative right
hilarious you might think nas you might
think is bringing their I might think
blowing yeah you might think [ __ ]
clear
I might think Connie yeah all relatives
but uh what an embarrassing thing to say
oh you know what else he'll allow TV and
he doesn't allow yeah and his staff
can't have sex unless they're married
now um I appreciate you guys he's got
problems he's got mental worst problems
I'm surprised no one's ever asked Kim
Kardashian how do you deal with his
insanity on a daily basis how I think
it's a pre-arranged thing but and
they're just it's a business decision
but how on an everyday basis are you
dealing with the craziness of this man
you hear him talk like oh [ __ ] I he's
out he's on medication she's more
creative without medication steam up
dealing on a day-to-day basis he's just
Croesus not all there no theme the
themes are made tonight if you're Kim
like what the [ __ ] did you know listen
man you know yeah that's uh I was I've
seen that my with my own eyes
I've seen like some people who are the
best famous is that and I stand I'm
seeing their spouse [ __ ] other dudes now
watching their spouse kind of realize
that they made a deal with the devil you
know there's so many blah married so I
feel like I gotta get out of this and
I can you know the but Kim's just the
same if not more famous than you know
he's ready to surpass so here's what's
about Connie so Jordans are billing it
right
Jordan owns 40% the Jordan Brand forty
to forty forty or fifty for something
like that of the Jordan Brand which is
Nike which is remakes all his money now
so he's a billionaire here's what's
crazy Kanye West's own 70% of Yeezy and
adidas so that's why they're saying tiny
is gonna leapfrog jay-z everybody in
hip-hop cuz he owns 70% it's like the
hottest he's a mogul
yeah but he's also this and this is
where I [ __ ] with Kanye as far as
business ition you know and he's talked
about like with Travis Scott who has
these great collabs with Nike and these
other guys who have great clouds of Nike
goes Nikes using you and paying you
let's say pay a million dollars a year
yeah and then there's how much are they
may come in shoes you don't own any of
that now so that's why he was and they
made his shoes so like his red Octobers
Easy's and his other disease or were so
much money but he's like no no kid I
know can get those this is ridiculous so
we're gonna draw a Dinah's was like give
me ownership let me create and I wanna
make the shoes certain models available
to everybody
yeah for a cheaper price yeah which what
he's done sure but he don't seventy
percent you don't st. 70 percent of easy
and easy to still no he just they just
released these Yeezy
free over the called 850 aliens
something like that ring them up let me
see what the new easy sir sorry I'm
nothing I'm not never learned I'm not
too unknown but
it's them it's the 380s the aliens look
they just released marks $1,200 right
now 1,200 see the middle one the second
ones inches ah yeah ah neck suck let's
see let's see these that I would never
work let's see these aren't for you no
they're comfortable so I probably cost
what temos 1,200 you saw 10 $15 if that
yeah and yet sold for what a great
profit margin that is that's incredible
I told you I've talked some guys to your
like street guys and they go oh we don't
sell drugs anymore oh no we're out drug
this we sell we sell Yeezys sell shoots
gets legal and the markups way higher
than anything else so they just they
hustle shoots drive Scots Easy's Wow Wow
the shoe market so interesting because
it's like it's created like this culture
where it's like people were like getting
murdered and robbed when they stay in
line for new pair of Jordans so they got
rid of that so now the big thing is is
like Nike released their Travis Scott on
Saturday at 7 a.m. 7 a.m. I set an alarm
at 6:55 done my [ __ ] ready to go so a
you got to download the app you got to
enter all your information on there and
here's what's crazy be you enter a
drawing so you enter drawing and
hopefully you get it I've never won on
there I've been on members for two years
and there one there this Saturday I won
I woke up my brother three floors down I
was so excited
let me see these [ __ ] shows you want
just so I can already hear first ones
they're not for yeah I know but I just
need to train more with he can so I can
okay hope you okay boomer what is boom
okay boomer what does that mean those
are what you wanna yep yes you'll like
them god dammit Brennan hey okay he's
over [ __ ] [ __ ] are they happy I [ __ ]
hate those shows okay boomer I'm not
boomer let's think sock man okay boomer
what [ __ ] what is it what is it shut up
top of them well I listen I like for a
trap shut up dude okay boomer I can i
okay boomer I can take the head call
babe
no what does he call me bozo so don't
call me bummer man
no it means my ladies I [ __ ] hate him
okay boomer hi call me boomer okay
boomer I'm getting mad
you should boom-boom I'm warning you bro
yeah those shoes aren't for you boomer
they're not for you
dude those shoes are so hard to get [ __ ]
you and those shoes here's the thing
you'll be just as a money investment I
could so I bought those how much I got
them for a hundred and eighty whatever
from the that's the standard price I
flip them like this for I don't know
eight hundred tomorrow I get em off no
boomer are you gonna wear them yeah I
wear this yo my shoes again drive the
[ __ ] my cars wear my shoes all right
but they're why are they so terrible
dude what do you mean those are sick if
I take the top off I don't know what
they're doing this what are ya what is
that top I have no idea but it's
removable because movie.i oh no I went
where if that was if they're stuck like
that you can take it off and it's a
normal ear first one the most
comfortable shoe the most iconic shoe
besides by the the the Jordan why
haven't they done black ones like that
okay boomer Hey Airport I never wear
them but I thought I bought him because
they were little white chairs show
comfortable they're so comfortable but
they're high tops
okay bloomer why is he calling me boomer
it says here in New York Times writer
Taylor Lorenz defines okay boomer as
generations ease endlessly repeated
retort to the problem of all the people
who just don't get it because you know
she was getting heckled by this guy yes
she just goes okay boomer from the
podium and now it's like the biggest
okay boom who said that who was saying
that our gretchen the the the little
girl shut the [ __ ] about the worth the
earth be announced on fire the pollution
all that oh yeah the ozone or whatever
but some she was choosing New Zealand
and she was heckled by an old member of
parliament who she was giving a speech
on climate crisis and she just went okay
boomer
oh there's a different person than right
you Chloe Swarbrick there it is my
generation and the generations after me
do not have that luxury and the year
2050 I will be 56 years old yet rights
now the average age of this 52nd
Parliament is 49 years old
okay Burma current political
institutions have proven okay boomer
incompetent that's why I say do you know
anytime you don't know what we're
talking okay boomer see how smooth that
was for me too
yeah you take a quick the other okay
boomer and sever yeah nice here that's
not okay that's okay boomer let's just
work merch which I would take let's
start okay boner where girl go okay
boner we're talking our debt okay hello
in a boom wait can I see I'm the what
those shoes without the top there's as
regular huh and Google there's a Velcro
there right there oh I see nope nope did
there there's no picture with it off
trust me and take it off boomer here
there it is
it looks way better the whole thing yeah
art come on dude that multiple get
multiple colors it's almost like
Nightmare Before Christmas
it's so sick I remember for Christmas
I'm so excited for them when I got the
notice that went you you success you won
dude I'm in my undies bro pee pee stains
out the front
[ __ ] breath in the morning here's all
crazy I've gone yeah my brother goes you
did not your brother's just like you and
I takes you went okay boom I even set
the delay I went look who when he goes
get the [ __ ] out of here cuz he knows he
knows yeah he does huh but he's 40
that'll is yeah he's getting to an age
where you boomer though well how old
when does this stop okay boomer
no dude stop call me boomer I don't like
it no the thing is the like the shoe
culture is always gonna be there dude I
know so yeah when you're in your forties
you're gonna be doing this rocking
awesome she
and taking care myself be careful ya
boomer be careful with the awesome
though well I mean cuz like this is just
all I got my off-white nineties I mean
and my Daniel Ricciardo stance socks I
mean I wish I I wish I wasn't like this
I wish I could wake up every day we're
in the same hey how about this how about
this I'm at the [ __ ] Rams game a guy
goes yo I saw you last night at the
Comedy Store
everybody looks at me they're like that
and then punch people who recognize me
the guy and he's like four rows awesome
because you swear to god he goes like
this he goes he goes I couldn't believe
it I ran away I was like god damn it
it's hilarious it was so funny and he's
right I'm gonna hate shots ain't dead
we're in the same thing back there bang
no makes eyes mind to it I'm laying it
up on the same day no never
obviously I clean playing you just nope
just a tumor and I keep my whistle clean
always I clean my will just stop again
that your [ __ ] waxed I have me to my
you've done this you know my golly in
the valley I do I'm not going to have my
ass weigh it waxed that would hurt too
yeah let be done do it nice and nice and
clean I want my whistle clean at all
times
sick yeah all right what else yep um
there's a bunch here let's see about
this one first you know that Airlines
pilot and this is at Denver Airport I
guess there's a Westin inside that
Airport that has hotel rooms have when
it was oh yeah so that big windows that
face the lobby as well okay so this
pilot was there and then he would he was
taking a phone call but he was naked
right just took off his clothes and
answered her phone calls in his hotel
room in his hotel room but the blinds
were all open okay so he's walking
around for like 24 minutes just talking
naked on the floor it's his right yeah
and the people were saying that he was
doing lewd acts which there was no
evidence to show but he was also naked
so he got arrested he actually went to
jail from two days before you can see
interested in your hotel room because
you're exposing yourself to people even
though your your hotel room he didn't
realize that the windows people could
see through
you know a lot of them are tinted yeah
but anyway so he wanted $300,000
settlement before that [ __ ] yeah food
for three of them no where's his job no
no he was suspended with pay for six
months until he figured everything I got
a vacation 300g yeah well what's this
that's just other stuff on this page
yeah let's not look at that stuff dude
have you see what's happening [ __ ]
Tokyo man no the protests now you're
talking about Hong Kong Hong Kong yeah
sorry I've seen the protein out now the
government saying that they're gonna
start using live in a circus were the
Chinese government you see what happens
he's my rock do know they I think it's
Iraq Whitney coming straight out things
direct so they're protesting so you know
what you know what the government did
they took away Wi-Fi and texting their
phones don't work so you can't report
what's going on Crandall oh yeah scary
[ __ ] man yeah now this is the this when
they go you know SEC amendment and guns
and stuffs like all right yeah when I
see I see what you say that's what the
Second Amendment yeah that government
oppression aids I like what Ben Shapiro
said about he goes left-wing people
anti-government gun and gun control
people are totally in the guns they just
want the cops to have them not you yeah
they're still in the guns it's like you
need guns so it's a question of how much
do you want to give the government all
the guns or would you like to have some
recourse that's all you can come [ __ ]
I'm telling ya Iraq I think they're
acknowledged II where they can take your
ak-47 your ar-15 they have drones and
everything else so oh yeah
the US Army they can shoot you from
where you can't see the helicopter you
can't see the Allen okay boomer pretty
good hey I know about military [ __ ]
I don't like you're saying I'm just
saying cuz you're gonna make me I got
your new training boomer but I've been
dreaming boom boom boom boom I'm gonna
embarrass you in front of your sensei
he's gonna see this you know I can't get
a black belt next week what's the
problem you two on one dude boom boom
sit down no
now what's this don't make me roll out
now ah so make me roll out and [ __ ] up
the studio raw this heel hook boomer
boomer sit down okay today okay boomer
two-on-one is he teaching you two on one
on the back - yeah did I quit don't
worry about what he's teaching me [ __ ]
where I'm very comfortable yeah yeah
yeah I know you're gonna do something
you're learning okay okay I'm good good
careful now okay
it's six to one
it's good
let's get stuff know how we good good
roll it's good roll a [ __ ] my defense
skin there dude
pretty good don't like that it's not fun
on my throat let's take those tasty
uh-huh
tasty here juicy yeah you don't have a
prawn killing man huh don't you if you
wanted you could defend right no I mean
I could if I we were going crazy if we
come to the mat I'm not gonna go here
come the mat the mat 861 I gotta do it
here and I use all my [ __ ] this [ __ ]
another [ __ ] man
um all right Thanksgivings what next
week right and in Toms matures me I
think it is next Thursday next Wednesday
me and Bryan Callen theis house oh yeah
Wednesday Wednesday I'm sorry dear
should we get with us we have the usual
suspects maybe we get Rogan down let's
figure it out who we want has that other
boomers who we want it's all boomers to
fall boom I'm gonna be so hard to finish
sick thanks buddy you're too strong
whatever technique you know yeah you do
a lot of technique really crunches
throughout there you have so much
technique huh did it for awhile like it
was your job like riding a bike
my favorite quote in the that movie wind
river how well do you know this land
like it's my job because it is that's a
great movie it's a great mommy
phenomena dude you know I watch his
peanut butter Falcon was shot I heard it
was good I haven't seen I heard parasite
which is a Korean movie doesn't have you
seen it no but hers was real funny I
don't watch those parasite I want to see
Joker cuz I'm yeah and then when Shia
LaBeouf is so good man oh and I won't
see the Irishman yes for sure
she moves I have to see peanut butter
Falcon he's something else isn't he show
buff is so good I'm good yeah yeah all
right guys listen good roll huh you'll
break down some [ __ ] shits is that it
you want more you got anything else more
yeah there's a few more so turkeys while
turkeys are going crazy in New Jersey
Thomas I got attacked by turkeys bite
Walter turkeys and I have it on video
they're violent they chased me nobody
believed me and we came back and they
chased me and Amanda around a car yeah
surely they're really they're really
violent these they see there's
territorial so they come running at you
oh and it was a shark and they saw me
and they started running
add me mm-hmm and they try to Peck you
listen man I celebrate all the animals
it's well-documented I love animals yeah
it's gonna be like I want to be like
Crocodile Hunter when I was kid is you
all just sure that's what we thought I
was gonna be I hate birds
I do not like birds you lead a turkey no
I don't like Turkey
I don't like birds on like turkey on a
bunch of turkeys came at you I'll shoot
no if you didn't have a gun you're gonna
choke him up yeah
stupid [ __ ] beat hey I don't like
birds man I don't like them they're
killers there's no life in them they're
dead bury their dead behind the other
side basically reptiles thing we have
the dinosaurs chin used to have birds
remember that [ __ ] hate birds I had
battles I had a scar laughing all right
they're right item calico McCall and a
blue and gold macaw dude I don't know if
I post it or not on Twitter
I think Rex Chapman who's the I don't
know if it's the ex basketball players
shout the Charlotte Hornets but he has a
count on there this lady who adopts this
dog who's like beaten and just like it
was like tortured and she adopts them
and they're driving home from the from
the agency and she's driving he's in the
shotgun he's grabbing her and just like
so thankful she starts crying it's all
right gonna say the dog attack I know so
I thought if I get ripped her face off
and that's why you don't adopt never
Glee [ __ ] dog yeah
are you so happy oh dude if tears your
heart because the dot you see the dog
like just so happy to be like with a
lovely my uncle my uncle there's a
golden retriever and they kept it
chained in the backyard and my uncle one
day went over and took that dog and that
dog would never go near that backyard
they you know you can't do that [ __ ] huh
on a chain and I hate that they just
throw food out there for Tourette's
that's how most dogs live their lives at
the end of a chain yes it's our country
absolutely that's how you live your life
if you're a pit bull yeah I mean makes
all the sense but yeah you live your
goddamn label I mean I [ __ ] hate
birds dude I don't trust them
you're saying you ever seemed like on
that nature's metal rampage yeah it'll
show like a [ __ ] bird poking the
brains out of the other yet
well Perkins you've seen the check out
the go peregrine falcon take a road
where they do two birds in midair look
they'll dive at 180 miles an hour and
then just boom turgon frog loon yeah
it's alright it's a punch yeah [ __ ] yeah
give the [ __ ] falcon attack I talk
about that peanut butter Falcon [ __ ]
either
yeah attack is the real [ __ ] watch this
[ __ ] that real bird [ __ ] now alright
we'll see how much we can show this Sony
you know the Smithsonian see me about
this I love the way he speaks I love the
way David Attenborough speaks to watch a
bird they are magnificent creatures
unaware unaware starlings a memory all
right get to it over 200 miles now does
it show the attack yeah it's just wrong
footage
yeah pigeon Wow look at this drawn
footage looks looks fake um and they do
with drones hmm that was cool hmm you
say they feel that they hit him you just
boom and you just see feathers in the
air no things good what else you got
check oh there's one yeah herds on birds
I'm not a bird fan Peregrine I hate
birds they're [ __ ] evil man hey take
it easy yeah if you own what it's
different
Harry it was the shittiest [ __ ] pet
it was trained when we've got it
and then after staying at the house for
like two months it just went feral and
it would fly around the house and like
all you would see is claws you out like
close the door just here a little bit
they have to walk like that so they have
to waddle around [ __ ] you get to
perch and waddle but be careful of the
dog and I hate birds what else get Jen
this guy from New Orleans he posed as a
mentally handicapped and physically
handicapped guy as his brother actually
and they use an app to get health care
providers to come over to the house
take care of him and wipe his ass when
he took shits cuz you get turned on by
that yeah I got turned on by it so he
posed as his mentally ill brother to get
women to wipe his ass my god what a
weirdo he's yeah even his face looks
like having his butt well look at his
face in a dye he's into having his butt
wipe town yeah he got some sort of
sexual pleasure from it of course he did
push yeah I'm a baby I'm clean my pool
hole ten separate occasions and then one
of the charge is sexual what is it
called obtained or rather no no no no
that uh trafficking special trafficking
because I guess you're paying them money
to do something sexual didn't realize
they del a lot of the stuff gets thrown
out you base that's not gonna hold up
anybody it wasn't sexual El Chapo's wife
is gonna be on a vh1 reality series
she's gonna be in a few parents satify
it too I mean I can't believe they're
actually doing that that's I feel like
you wouldn't touch that area you know
anything cartel crew I guess they have
like a bunch of descendents from you
know cartel members or mafia members
doing that show and she's gonna make a
few appearances there she's pretty hot
she had a lot of work done all of them
do on that show yeah a lot of wives
don't say anything this is a little
older but it's very heartwarming Alex
Trebek I know this was yes I guess his
cancers not going great I mean he's
Stage four pancreatic that is a breeze
Norway July girls grandma Stage four
yeah it's not it's that's not the cancer
you want do you have you seen this no oh
[ __ ] let's do the TMZ you want to think
it's heartbreaking it's cute but let's
take a look at your response did you
come up with the right one no what is we
love you out that's very kind thank you
costea 1995 you're left with a five
bucks okay
[Music]
yeah man
that's tough what an idiot huh
kettle one that's great I get emotional
because I'm dead behind the eyes but
still plus I'm all I think about is you
two lately ain't that crazy though yeah
pretty sad that's really nice that's
pretty much it Phoenix date huh I'll be
in Phoenix on the 21st of December at
the Comedy Theatre will not elaborate e
theater one night only yep celebrity
theater and then I'm in Boston at the
Wilbur on New Year's
I can't wait yeah I'm psyched and then I
guess I'm in Nashville January 9th 10th
and 11th
daddy's hitting the road again yeah
Cleveland on January Mussoorie not
filming anymore well we don't know but
it looks like I might be we don't know
yet huh and you lined up these dates
already I don't know what's going on I
have to say what's what
you know I'm saying yeah now I'm in Salt
Lake City this week dude Thursday Friday
Saturday wiseguys with my favorite clubs
and then next week it's Wednesday night
before Thanksgiving yes my newborn
subpoena my newborn will be opening up
for the show he's doing first ten
minutes you'll hold your newborn up and
just Christian them to see the state
line Kane's Mitzi short who the owner of
the comedy store used to the legend is
she'd let Pauly Shore cry in Ex crib and
they'd be like you guys now I'm getting
him used to bombing like any mom of the
Year award doing this yeah yeah telly
see turn okay he did act he is he's
great dude I love Paula well you know on
the podcast - but I keep when I see me
as I do one Mike come on I got a column
I just remember I do a show Wednesday so
and now that so we'll figure it out
we do need us yo Nick yes Thanksgiving
special what
let me turn duck in these nuts in your
mouth we're home so so like City wise
guys this week Thursday Friday Saturday
Ice House with Bryan Callen and Friends
next Wednesday once your only 10:00 p.m.
then December 6 through the 7th I'm in
Kansas City Friday and Saturday
Atlantic City one-eyed
only December 14th Borgata and December
super thicky for me and then la jolla
Comedy Store
December 19th through the 21st get your
tickets at t f-- at kake.com
home idea buddy buddy I like where your
gist is that keep it up not bad right
keep it up good keep it up
you uh you want to come down and really
shake it up you know where to find me
right bro okay boom okay this the fine
kid we're out